[Music]
I think the curiosity is high only
undervalued phenomenon if you will
because you can't really always explain
it sure there's some base things that
we're curious of Howard gears about
eating work here is around other people
but sometimes we're curious about things
that we just can't explain to ourselves
and that's something that we shouldn't
underestimate because that is a force
that draws us into the world unlike any
other you can't fake curiosity if you're
curious about something you're curious
about it and that's it and it doesn't
require any more explanation but I do
think that it requires significantly
more investigation so if you're curious
about a subject matter or a project or a
problem in the world or something like
that I think it's our responsibility to
figure out how we can cultivate that
curiosity right in an all-or-nothing
world I feel like a lot of times we
immediately set this expectation that we
have to become an expert in everything
right and I think that that sets us up
for failure we have to have a lot of
knowledge or no knowledge at all but our
curiosity is simply the needle in our
inner compass pointing towards something
and compasses aren't don't point true
north right so essentially it's up to us
to figure out what that curiosity
actually is so how do we cultivate our
curiosity practically the best way that
I found is through sprints and Sprint's
are essentially self-contained micro
goals and they're structured to be less
than 30 days long so ideally a week or
two they have no barrier to entry so you
don't have to wait for anybody or
anything you can get started today and
they have to have a clearly defined set
of tasks or actions so you can get
started these Sprint's will allow you to
cultivate your curiosity because you'll
focus on one small aspect of something
that could be significantly larger and
then once you're done with that sprint
you can take a step back and see what
did that sprint teach you what exactly
were you curious about
are you still curious about this or
did all of a sudden your curiosity shift
so essentially through Sprint's you're
able to learn very specific goals a
which is great you know if you are
curious about cooking for example maybe
you learn knife skills and in that
process you start learning more about
cooking but you still have the knife
skills even if you walk away from that
project altogether Sprint's are really
great because they allow us to try
things on for size without wasting a lot
of time and energy and they allow us to
build over time on these curiosities you
can take one sprint and then follow it
with another sprint in another sprint
and those Sprint's will change depending
on what you learn along the way so that
way you can take something very big and
seemingly overwhelming and break it down
into very actionable steps
[Music]